and communication technology  professional with talent and passion the  European Commission is looking for ICT  specialists and assistance as temporary  agents to join various services in  Luxembourg a few posts are also  available in Brussels  play a role in defining and implementing  ICT policies and translating business  needs into ICT solutions analyze  statistical and big data to find smart  solutions or support the implementation  of challenging projects with your  knowledge of two EU languages diversity  and equality are two of the --use  founding principles so it's institutions  offer everyone a fair chance to make an  impact on Europe's future expand your  learning enhance your skills and take  the next step in your career what are  you waiting for shaping Europe together